what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in let's get
started so today
you know guys we've had this question
can you turn a hoe into a housewife I
think that's been a question I want to
say for as old as time but really that's
developed in the last hundred years
and you know what led me to this
question today is Will Logan Paul
still marry this model after everything
that's come out so Dylan danis and Logan
Paul have a fight coming up they are
both Fighters and they had one coming up
and some people may not know that
there's a bit of history of some beef
between these guys so I guess you know
Dylan was dating a chick right and I
guess when maybe when they broke up
Logan decided to sleep with this chick
and then they made a video basically dis
and Dylan
um where you know she kind of eludes
that she's on the Paul Brothers
that they'd hooked up right you know
that she was kind of doing stuff with
them now and so clearly Dylan did not
forget this you know I have to say Logan
did throw the first punch
and now we have this Twitter beef so you
know about
like a month ago now Logan actually
proposed to this his you know new
girlfriend
and you know Dylan took this opportunity
to you know really dig into this girl's
past because apparently Logan didn't do
it so
um pull the clip
she belongs to the street
foreign
I'd rather be like naked in front of
like 100 people
oh it keeps going
guys I think that was over a hundred
pictures and you see what happens in
society you know where we have
she seems like a nice girl but this is a
hundred pictures
like when you turn homes into wives now
you know Logan has all this money and he
has this big fight coming up and now his
fiance is basically embarrassing him and
giving everyone else something to clown
him about and that's the problem in
society is that really we just got a
bunch of 304s as wives and now the
internet it never forgets it never
forgets so
you know now the question is was there
any warning signs that this was going to
happen let's let's pull pull the clips
and like got to Lake Como I've been
dreaming about getting to the specific
hotel since I saw it and like I walked
in and Gregory the like you know general
manager was there and he knew about
everything but like was playing it so
cool
um at the most amazing day like we both
like looked at each other and we were
just like you were like this is the most
content I've ever felt you started
crying you remember that when we eat
that Panini emotional day for me that
was a good evening how I get it it
wasn't a [__] El Panini it was so
good though
um and then got to bed dinner thing and
like I said when we first started this
podcast I've been so intentional about
keeping things between us between us you
are not an internet piece of Click bait
for me you're my everything babe I
[__] love you so much now i have to
just point out a couple things
when the guy is putting the woman on a
pedestal now you know it's one thing if
she's like a 22 year old virgin right
but this is a 31 year old model that's
that's been around
everybody you know and you're to the
point where you're like crying
and he said you're my everything and I
really think that men are in a dangerous
position nowadays when they put a woman
so high on a pedestal that she's
literally his everything and you know I
think it really just messes up the
natural order I have very old-fashioned
like views on this I really think the
natural order of the world is God men
women children and the problem is when
you're putting a woman on a pedestal
you're putting her above you and
relationships just do not work like we
hate men that put us on a pedestal we
hate it we cannot stand it and you know
I think Society has lied to men with
Disney fairy tales and all of this stuff
where guys you know drop everything for
the woman and they think that works and
unfortunately it really leads to bad
outcomes and what I would say is
predatory women women that learn the
game and then
they just learned to play it really well
and and get the first suckers you're my
everything babe I [__] love you so
much and so I don't I don't want to drag
you into this shitstorm sorry guys
watching but it's a [__] hell hole
online and it is what you make it you
have iron skin dude we posted our our
first picture together like oh like
girlfriend six month anniversary and the
the comments are just scathing just
being mean to Nina just I've never been
bullied my entire life I don't know how
and then obviously you have a couple of
things in your past that I did not know
you personally and it definitely you
know I was I wasn't sure I wanted to
be associated with that and now you're
my fiance but that's because we've
talked it all through but like if you
don't know Logan and I totally get it
like if you just see you know the
headlines and the stupid [__] that
people like to write about you and they
love to pick on people that are doing
well that are good people at the same
time because that's just how the world
works I didn't really know if if this
was the right job for me at that point
in time so I declined it but it was
honestly mostly because of the money
this might this might be too far I don't
know where's the line I she wouldn't she
wouldn't have sex with me I know that
for a while well it wasn't it wasn't uh
a while because it wasn't measured in
days
I feel like this this subject is
finished for sure right yeah yeah I I
will say so yeah you you no you
approached that phenomenally like you
you you not
having sex with me for the duration of
time that you did was very important you
thought something was wrong with me I
I'll be honest I thought I did you talk
you talked to Mike about it I said this
this girl's perfect as far as I can tell
there's one unexplored
Venture and I I have reason to believe
that there's probably something wrong
with it because if it's too good to be
true it probably is do do you believe
that that waiting period had a a long
long effect and and led to the this
moment no
I do I absolutely do
so this is what I mean by predatory
women
um you know because you know some people
might say maybe that's a bit extreme but
this chick
had sex with all of these guys and I
know some are just pictures so I I don't
know but you know she she sleeps with
all of these dudes for a decade and then
is making the guy that is gonna marry
her weight and you can kind of tell in
his language that he still has more of
like a blue pill thinking like he he
says she's perfect she's my everything
and unfortunately like that mentality
just isn't good for a guy to have you
know I think again it's telling men to
adopt a more feminine mindset because a
girl that thinks like the world and
thinks her guy is perfect like that's a
relationship that works a hell of a lot
better than a guy that thinks his girl
is perfect because again I just think
there's a natural hierarchy of things
and I think that it's supposed to go God
men women children
and if you don't look up to your husband
I just think it's a recipe for disaster
and the truth of the matter is he's the
one putting her on a pedestal when this
is a 31 year old chick that's been
sleeping with dudes for a decade she's
the one that's lucky but she thinks
she's better than the multi-millionaire
probably future billionaire
you know YouTuber and I just think this
is the problem in society and this is
kind of going to be a theme in today's
like whole show is that we're telling
average women they can get exceptional
outcomes and that we deserve exceptional
outcomes like you can just tell by her
body language she doesn't even feel
lucky to be there and again that's the
problem when a chick has experienced too
much when she does get a good thing you
know Instagram has made the average
chick a celebrity
um you know average women on Instagram
get more attention and live lives closer
to celebrities than
the biggest celebrities 50 60 years ago
and it's crazy because I've just noticed
a trend of like average chicks like
blowing up and it's never and I don't
know if the algorithm manufactures it or
maybe they're more relatable I don't
really know why
but I've just noticed like average
chicks like that that one chick you know
had that the the really good podcast and
that just blew up and I've noticed this
trend of average women getting
exceptional outcomes and the problem
guys is us women are so addicted to
attention we all got social media you
know these days at like 10 years old and
you have to understand that women on
social media is the equivalent of men
being addicted to porn
and a lot of people don't make this
equivalent but women it's like what what
do women desire right we desire
like if you ask the chick
you can get you can have sex with
whoever you want the rest of your life
or you don't get sex but you get Beauty
the rest of your life you get to look
like you're 20 until you die
I I would hypothesize that more chicks
would pick attention now the beauty the
youth but men on the other hand like a
guy if you ask a guy you could have sex
with supermodels the rest of your life
or you could look like you're 20 the
rest of your life I think more guys or
be super good looking but you don't have
sex like guys want sex women want
attention and it's just we have
different currencies so we essentially
have a bunch of
women that have been given Celebrity
level attention from the day we were
like 10 you know these days women are
getting social media like 10 years old
the issue we get with Nina is you know
now there's a digital footprint for
everybody to see but I've noticed this
trends of average women getting
exceptional outcomes not only in the
media
um and partially partially I do think
this is whole flation because again you
know 100 years ago pretty much all the
guys got a virgin so by you know 2023 if
you're not a virgin you would have been
a hall 100 years ago I I don't make the
rules right I know that's not the same
definition in modern times but if we're
going to go from a historical point of
view it is very unusual to be in a time
period where the women are not virgins
again like I do think that men have to
work 10 times harder for a chick that's
a lot more average than their
grandfathers and their
great-grandfathers would have gotten so
and I see this trend continue in
Hollywood where average chicks are
getting exceptional outcomes and you
know I I noticed this because I was
thinking that I haven't seen a Megan Fox
level of hot chick in forever and I was
thinking of how you know women with
acting careers used to kind of stop at
like 30 maybe 35 they would make it to
but I've noticed that like women like
Sandra Bullock Jennifer Aniston are
still getting booked for really really
big roles you know recently we had a
Barbie movie and all of Twitter was set
Ablaze because everyone was arguing if
Margot Robbie was hot or if she was mid
and you know I gotta be honest Margot
Robbie was definitely a Barbie level of
hot at 22 but at 32 you know I think you
could go to any college campus and find
chicks better looking I think I've had
chicks better looking on on the show you
know I don't think it's that uncommon
but it's interesting because it used to
be that in Hollywood to be an A-list
celebrity you had to be a certain level
of good looking and I've just seen this
trend you know really change so I want
to first show you guys the hot
celebrities of you know like 10 15 years
ago so here we got Megan Fox
right oh
beautiful I know she's like crazy now
but I'm sorry this chick is is stunning
okay the next one
now we have Mila Jovovich
again
stunning right I don't think anyone
would really discount that that's at
least an eight or higher okay
Halle Berry you know I'm I'm not a fan
of the short hair I really don't believe
women should have short hair but she
could pull it off why
she's an eight or higher and the way I I
do a similar scale to Kevin Samuels
where you know four to six is like
average normal looking
sevens don't really exist we don't
really rate people sevens um eights or
higher
is like Hollywood you know traditional
modeling contracts not not what they
have today now we got Sierra you know
this is one of the number one women
that I get on the show and it's
interesting because when I would ask men
celebrity crushes I just noticed a trend
of guys only naming celebrity crushes
from 10 15 20 years ago and I would
never hear guys mention any chick from
today not really okay so now we have the
celebrities of today and I would rate
most of these chicks adjustable sixes I
would say they're all above average
they're all cute
none of them are these stunningly
beautiful women we had of 10 20 years
ago they're not Jennifer Aniston they're
not Angelina Jolie now we have Jenna
Ortega again like cute right but
is she Megan Fox level
I I would say no okay I'm not a guy so I
want all the guys to let me know in the
comments Jenna Ortega I would maybe put
her seven seven okay
now we have our favorite actress
she looks exactly like the last chick to
me they look
literally exactly the same we have the
Snow White Star very you know humble
chick right there
um but again these are like 18 19 20
year olds being told they're like the
next hottest thing when really they're
just kinda
average chicks and what seemed to be
like propped up nowadays so that was
that's Rachel zegler again I'd give her
six you know strong six and this is
Millie Bobby Brown and Millie Bobby
Brown is like the number one actress
right now
um like out of all these chicks I know
her the most and she's really good she's
actually so talented but again
sex sex yeah cute right definitely cute
none of them ugly but it's like
you know I kind of miss watching TV and
feeling bad about myself and I feel like
Hollywood has taken this away from me
you know I used to open a magazine and I
would see women Megan Fox Angelina Jolie
and I would just leave
feeling a little bad I'm like damn I'll
never look like that but you know you
still appreciate the beauty you it's
like so you know I would go to a
basketball game or a volleyball game and
I would feel a little bad you know and I
really feel like
Hollywood has taken away the hierarchy
of beauty we used to reward the most
beautiful people and that was the
standard to be in Hollywood but for
whatever reason
um I really just think Hollywood doesn't
want to appeal to the male gays anymore
they want to appeal to the female gays
and therefore they're going to do less
attractive women you know so us chicks
don't feel bad but I say no no we are
supposed to see the best of the best
it's like when you go to the Olympics
you don't go there to see average people
play sports when we go to Hollywood when
we go to
when we open a magazine when I see a
model I I want to be inspired I wanna I
wanna be able to pull off the off the
magazine and like put it on my fridge so
I eat less
I really just think that the people in
charge you know
they want us stupid that way we are easy
to control and when women are by
ourselves which we really are
in this economy like we really are more
and more now that we have more single
women than ever more divorced women than
ever and just women as a whole we have
more power than ever you know
um they can just run a couple ads and
convince us that average chicks can date
these crazy above average guys and you
know what I noticed I noticed too in a
lot of like the romance movies nowadays
like you know women we loved 50 Shades
of Gray
and what is that it's an average six of
a chick cute chick
dating a guy that's like a
multi-billionaire
and they go off and they live happily
ever after like at least before
with Snow White and like you know
Cinderella you knew you couldn't have
those outcomes unless you were really
really hot okay that was like the
standard like okay ladies you could
maybe ride off into the sunset with a
prince if you're really hot but now
social media has us all convinced that
we're just eights nines and tens and you
see girls in the media you know that are
convinced they're eights nines and
eights nines and tens and you convince
average chicks that we can just have
these crazy outcomes and it's so funny
because I just think in the old
generation you would see like TMZ and
you would see all of these celebrities
but you knew it wasn't real life but
because us chicks you know have access
to these guys we would never in a
million years have access to it makes us
live like
not you know real lives until we hit
like 35 and you know everything crashes
down
but you never know they could just take
away women's right to vote and this
whole thing would be done
okay so Britney Spears
you know uh was one of those celebrities
that I really remember pretty early on
in my childhood like I don't remember
when the first time I heard of her was
so I don't remember how old I was
exactly but I remember when she was just
going nuts like she was shaving her head
she was like walking around half naked
and you really see this trend of like
you know I noticed this after I became
like more red pilled
that women from a young age if you just
get bombarded with a ton of attention
it's really not good for us and I think
that's why you see these like young
women just going absolutely nuts like
you know the Disney Channel kids when
you really think about the Disney
Channel kids like Demi Lovato Miley
Cyrus they're mostly women that go nuts
it's really I mean there's some guys but
when I when I think of the famous people
that have gone crazy it again is more
the women and the the child stars that I
didn't see go crazy honestly again they
were under the authority of a man
usually their dad protected them and
what happened with Britney Spears is she
was going absolutely insane to the point
that her ex-husband got custody of her
kids
do you know how hard it is to lose
custody as a chick do you know about it
like literally we go into the courts and
it's like easy mode like they just hand
us our kids where if you lose custody
like you're I don't want to say it
depends on the state
but you know by and large broad brush
Strokes here you're probably a shitty
mom but for some reason women we love
being victims
we love being victims so
um her dad put her under a
conservatorship which basically means
he's in charge of her money and she
can't post freely like there's a bunch
of stuff that she's not allowed to do
and there was this whole campaign on
social media saying free Brittany and
Brittany started you know getting
through the posting and she's like I
need to be freed and the problem is when
women and you know honestly what
happened to Brittany shows a broader
Trend in society we ask for freedom and
the men say fine
here you go you know because the man you
can just wear them down you know they
just they just don't want to fight they
just want peace so you're like police
can I have this freedom I want this
Freedom then they give us this freedom
and everything goes to hell and that's
what happened to Britney Spears you know
she took her dad to court and they gave
her her Freedom now she's half naked
dancing on the internet you cannot tell
me that's a better outcome for women or
for her oh oh I forgot about this part
she wasn't allowed to have kids they put
an IUD up her
and you would think okay normally okay
guys normally
we're pro kids Pro family but do you
know how crazy you have to be
for them to be like oh no
oh no you cannot make babies we need to
legally make it so you cannot have
children
and this is the problem when you have
like a feminist mindset you always view
men as like the bad guys
so you're always going to view men as
out to get you so you know when the
internet came forward with the story
everyone was like everyone viewed her
dad as this evil man when really he was
just looking out for her you know dads
typically want what's best for their
daughters and men are pretty logical so
if he was putting an IUD in her
not him like actually but like they had
a doctor or whatever there was probably
a good reason for it and again that's
how we have to look at history too we
really have to understand that like
people were making the best decisions
for the time and it's the same thing
with with her dad you know on paper it's
like that looks pretty crazy you know
she's
she can't have kids she has no freedom
but you know now she's literally going
insane in front of her eyes so her
husband Sam ask Hari ask Hari guys you
know me I just can't do names I can't do
it has issued the first statement since
reports emerged that he was filing for
for divorce from his wife pop star
Britney Spears on Wednesday August 16th
it was reported that the couple was
separating after just a year of marriage
in the statement posted online the model
and fitness trainer said that he and
Spears hold on to the love and respect
they have for each other but they're
falling for divorce after a year
so this is the trend that we're going to
keep seeing gold digger men now it's
never gonna get as bad as women like
that they'll change the laws before that
happens but you are going to see a trend
of men going after women's money so you
know as Hari acknowledged that asking
for privacy seems ridiculous but ask
that the media and the public be kind
and thoughtful the court documents filed
at at a court in Los Angeles this week
cited and reconcilable differences for
divorce for the divorce and revealed
that Askari and Spears had separated
almost like three weeks ago in a post on
his Instagram story he wrote after six
years of love and commitment to each
other my wife and I have decided to end
our journey and it's so funny because
women have been doing this for years you
know he's with this chick for six years
he knew she was crazy it wasn't like he
didn't know
you know but
there's there's a bag involved we will
always hold on to the love and respect
for each other but I wish her the best
[__] happens asking for privacy seems
ridiculous but I will just ask everyone
including the media to be kind kind and
thoughtful
in a separate statement issued to The
Hollywood Reporter a representative for
Askari denied media reports that he
threatened to release embarrassing
materials about Spears unless
concessions were made in the couple's
prenup there are many claims that Sam is
challenging the prenup and threatening
to exploit his ex-wife with video videos
Conan said
however all these claims are false as no
negative intention has ever been a
direct has ever been directed towards
her and never will be Sam have and
always will support her
however another article by Page Six
reported that Brittany has hired
celebrity divorce attorney Laura wasser
who boosts A-list clients such as Kim
Kardashian yeah Kim Kim came out Okay
Kevin Costner and Johnny Depp but it's
been alleged that asagi is threatening
to release
extraordinarily embarrassing information
about his spouse if she if she refuses
to renegotiate terms some sources close
to Spears told Daily Mail it's absurd it
was a page six reported that Wednesday
that oscari is focused on attempting to
negotiate concessions Beyond his prenup
and threatening to go public with
embarrassing information
if he doesn't get paid so you know it's
it's really a he said she said at this
point but you know
I guess we don't watch what they say we
watch what they do we really do have to
see this is a trend this is going to be
a growing Trend you know they were
together six years now they get married
it's guys he knew she was crazy he knew
that she should have been under that
sense because he knew that she should
have been under the conservatorship but
you know
he got the ring and you know he's
bouncing so you know there there could
be more to the story
I guess we'll just have to wait and see
so lastly today
I want to talk about how again we have
all these real reasons for divorce you
know us women have real reasons and in
2023 it's totally not about our selfish
interests it is always about the kids
and the family first yeah okay so we
have this story on Reddit you know of a
woman asking for advice on her marriage
so she says I think I need to leave my
husband but I don't know how hi all I'd
like some guidance or support honestly
whatever you can offer because I'm
exhausted by this and got
Pearl has guidance for you oh my gosh
thank you can I get like emails for me
to answer I think they would be
hilarious
um you know if you want if you wanted if
you want you know me to comment on your
story if you got something for me to
comment on just pearly things that Gmail
no don't put I don't want random people
emailing me never mind
um
we'll we'll make an email for it we'll
make an email okay I've 30 female been
with my husband 30 male for nine years
married for two and I've been thinking
more and more over the past six or seven
months about leaving him we haven't had
sex in over a year and I don't see that
changing as we have no emotional
intimacy this women an emotional
intimacy
emotional intimacy this is what I
realize chicks mean mean by this they
just mean he doesn't want to listen to
me Yap you know I have a chick you know
I've monetized Yap but us women we just
yap yap yap we talk about our day and we
just tell these guys all this stuff they
don't care about and after a certain
time you know guys will be nice to you
in the beginning but later they're like
tired they're like I'm done I don't want
to listen to this and then we cry
emotional intimacy instead of just
understanding that men and women really
are different
um and she said and that's something I
really need to maintain a sex life we
don't talk much
besides what do you want for dinner and
how was your day there's not really a
lot left that we have in common no dates
Etc
uh we had a really big blow up in Feb
it's like funny
we don't talk much it's so funny that's
like the kiss of death to a woman but if
a guy gets a chick that doesn't talk
much he's like Hallelujah he's like
thank you God so he's probably just
eating his dinner and he's like this is
nice we're just sitting in peace it's
just nice to like be with the chick I
love and she's thinking wow I have no
emotional intimacy this is terrible I
need to divorce him
we had a big blow up in February where I
told him I was unhappy and wanted to
leave it sort of fizzled out and we just
both promised to try as hard as possible
but six months later I'm just as unhappy
you see this you guys think I make this
stuff up women leave because they're not
happy
and she admits okay he's not a bad man
and he loves me I just don't think we're
compatible anymore and I can't help but
think I'm giving up the opportunity to
be in a much happier situation either
with someone else or alone I've started
to look at places to live so I can be
prepared to tell him I'm leaving and
mean it and have somewhere to go the
guilt is getting to me and I keep
thinking that this isn't what you do and
that I married him and made a commitment
so I should spend longer trying to see
if things turn around
like it's so interesting because
what if she didn't have a choice do you
think she'd figure out how to be happy
like if she knew she would have to work
imagine
she has to work
cleaning toilets the next 50 years
that's what the rest of your life looks
like
do you think she'd figure out how to
like figure it out and the one thing is
like women often think think because we
work we're there for like um
equal to the guy but the truth of the
matter is guys are gonna work longer
than us you're not going to be working
like you're working now in your 60s and
it and it the data shows you this
because women really Flatline their
income at like I think early 30s we
Flatline where the men flat line at like
65 so the men just keep going and women
it's like do you really want to be
working as hard as you are in your 50s
60s 70s
so okay I'd love some guidance or even
just support okay and it's so funny we
we tell each other what we want
in our language I'd love some guidance
or even some support from other women
who have been through this and come out
on the other side so she doesn't want to
hear from women who worked through it
and made it to the other side she
doesn't want to hear from women that
don't support this but I'm going to give
my my two cents anyway I know she was
just dying to talk to Pearl so hello
lady I'm here okay
what do you think your life is going to
be like
in your 30s so I don't know if you have
kids or not but you really gotta think
about this okay let's say you leave
do you think your dating options
are gonna be easier in your 30s
like they were 10 years ago okay let's
say let's say you have kids
do you think it's gonna be easier for
you dating and going on dates and saying
yeah I got Timmy Tom Tommy
and Jenna back at home
and do you really think your life is
going to be easier
in an apartment
with your kids where you're doing
everything yourself you have no Comfort
no support no help
it
is it really going to be easier and are
you really gonna be able to do better
because a lot of women Lee a lot of
women leave thinking that the grass is
greener on the other side that you are
then going to do better
and I'm here to tell you that I
interview chick after chick on my show
that left her husband and did not in
fact do better
you know so
well guys
what do you think do you think my advice
was was good you know I've always said I
don't give advice but I think I'm now
ready I'm ready for my my Reddit giving
advice days it's just welcome to pearls
Pearl's world it's kind of interesting
because we really went through the whole
story today we started with the Modern
Woman getting married Logan proposing
you know getting embarrassed after then
we have this woman that is married right
this story I just went over and she's on
the on the road to divorce
then we have Britney Spears's divorce
and now we're gonna get the divorce
attorney's input so pull the clip if you
break it down fundamentally 56 of
marriages end in divorce but think about
that's the ones that end in divorce so
how many people what percentage stay
together for the kids
or because they don't want to give away
half their [__] another 10 that's
conservative conservative but let's say
let's say 20 then okay that's at least
you now have a technology that fails 76
of the time that's insane that's insane
that's more likely than not 76 if I tell
you there's a 76 chance when you walk
out the door today you're gonna get hit
in the head with a bowling ball you
would not go out or you'd wear a helmet
for sure but people just continue to get
married not only do they continue to get
married there's a presumption
that you should get married and if you
don't get married there's something
wrong with you so if you've got a
girlfriend and you've been with her for
five years and you say to someone we're
getting married they go oh that's great
you know they don't go why you're happy
why would you get married like
everything's going fine why would you
put yourself through that why would you
run that risk if you say to someone
we've been together five years and we've
decided we're not going to get married
we're gonna move in together but we're
not going to get married ooh what's
wrong yeah intimacy issues what's your
problem meanwhile set 56 end in divorce
it's it's literally fits the legal
definition of negligence it's a
negligent Behavior the way you Define
negligence in law school is when what
you lose by not doing something okay
is lower than the risk of harm it's
what's called a BPL analysis so the
burden of not doing a thing is lower
than the likelihood the probability
of harm so BPL is a burden probability
and loss
marriage is an inherently negligent
activity it's like owning a lion like
it's it's it your the likelihood of
someone getting hurt seriously because
he's very very high no one ever says it
to you because why because
I've been doing this for over 20 years
and I I still get misty-eyed at weddings
like I still really there's something in
me that goes like you know maybe it'll
work out for these two
and it's really sad to think about
that honestly marriage it's not marriage
anymore you know marriage the woman is
supposed to be a virgin
and the woman is supposed to stay home
with the kids and unfortunately
these policies that have been passed by
our lawmakers you know no fault divorce
uh the invention of birth control really
have
um
ruined marriage in my opinion and that's
why I I don't really like Cookie Cutter
advice because I don't know how you can
advise a guy to get married with this
high of a divorce rate you know it's
almost like you're putting your world
view
um and I and I do like respect that
world view a lot like the traditional
conservative world view you know
um
I I do think that it's better for
society
if we have families and get married like
I do I really do but unfortunately like
the numbers I've seen guys they just
don't lie most guys are going to marry a
chick that's been with over five to
seven guys and we know now you marry
that chick you have a 20 chance of a
happy marriage twenty percent
where I mean if they're virgins it makes
sense then you have an 80 chance or you
know I'm gonna guess that that's still
gonna go down because
like The Virgins are just gonna get like
so much attention that they're gonna
turn like social media has really just
and it's interesting being like a
commentator and understanding this but
like social media really has just made
everybody crazy and it's really given us
women a delusional level of
self-importance unfortunately it's
ruined marriage social media birth
control
um no fault divorce
to the point where it's like I don't
really if I'm being honest I don't
really see a good reason for a guy to
get married in 2023
um the only way I really could see is if
she's a virgin but in 2023 how how many
chicks really are are they virgins and
they're in shape are they virgins and
they truly believe in biblical
submission because the issue too is you
have this feminist propaganda in the
churches where the women will weaponize
the Bible to control their husbands and
then start to say they'll only submit
when their husband follows God which is
you know just a way for them to control
just to control you
um and honestly I I don't it really is
hard being in the space of YouTube
because
it would be so much easier to just say
hey guys find a wife
find her young get married get married
get married like the Trad con and that's
a lot easier message to sell oh my gosh
guys do you know how much more money I
would make if I just sold that message
but I just can't tell you guys something
that's not true
and unfortunately you know as idealistic
as that is it's 2023 and the truth of
the matter is that
even a more pure woman is going to have
a ton of Temptation
um on the marketplace and you kind of
see that in the data where women that do
get married young and I do think getting
married young and staying married is
better for women
um unfortunately the chicks that get
married super young
um a lot of times feel like they're
missing out when everyone they know is
out partying when everyone is doing fun
stuff on social media they don't feel
like they're like a part of the party
and then you got chicks that basically
you know divorce their husbands because
they wanna
party they want to pursue their career
and I've literally talked to women that
have done this so people can't tell me
I'm making this [__] up because I've
talked to women that felt like their
husband was holding them back from doing
something
and the problem is when us women get too
much Freedom we become self-destructive
and I don't I don't say this I didn't
have these thoughts like two or three
years ago but it's really the only
natural conclusion I can come to when
women have too much Freedom we just go
crazy and right now we're all basically
attention [__] because we've all had
social media from the time we were like
10 years old and then we're we're sold
these fairy tales that were supposed to
have a prince charming out there that's
just gonna come find you and love you
and he's gonna have all of these he's
gonna be a a literal Prince
like we were told we were gonna get
literal princes
not you know like the truck driver or
like
you know like the plumber or
you know and and that's the problem
that's really the trend I see is like
women in our in our 20s we go for these
like entertainers these celebrities or
whatever like the highest guys we have
access to and then you know in our 30s
like like this chick you know some
chicks get lucky if they're hot enough
but a lot aren't and that's what the
data is showing us that half of us are
going to be single childless
and you know it's really just a sad
reality I came to this conclusion the
other day that we really have a society
of like lonely men and [__]
because again if we're gonna go buy a
historical point of view you would be a
concubine
if you weren't a virgin you were
someone's concubine
so you know it's kind of like
this is this is the society that women
have created if I'm being honest because
you know and it's interesting because
the Trad cons will always find a way to
blame that but it was a really small
percentage of men that had any say in
giving women all this power it was a
very small percentage of men and now I
look at what has happened when us women
have had too much freedom and too much
power we're not generally
good with it
um you know we've passed policies that
have
you know really discriminated against
men we've taken men's kids we've gotten
into a boatload of debt you know we have
this strand of like delusional women
that think we're all hotter than we are
and it's really
unfortunately especially as a chick we
are so um
like conforming like we're very much we
want to be accepted by the group that it
is really hard for women to not go with
the culture and even you know I I have
friends that homeschool their kids but
the culture still affects their kids
it's really tough to completely protect
your children from the culture
um when the whole world is going one way
and I really just don't see this going
well
um I I really think there's going to be
some sort of Decline and
at some point I do think men will take
power back I don't know when that'll be
uh in the foreseeable future I don't
really see it going that way and again
this is why I really don't think women
should have gotten the right to vote and
I know this sounds like a crazy opinion
everyone thinks I'm so insane for this
opinion and I and I really get it you
know I think if I heard this opinion
like two years ago I would have had the
same thing but again we're messing up
the natural order of the world and I
just noticed that evil happens when it
when we mess up the order of God
men women children and when women think
we're equal to men which equal voting
rights insinuates were equal to men evil
happens evil policies have been passed
you even the people that think women
should vote you can't argue with me that
abortion was a good policy
that right there 29 of all pregnancies
today end in abortion
one out of three pregnancies end in
abortion one out of three
that that is the culture that's happened
since women got power you know uh 200
years ago each woman had seven kids
a hundred years ago we had three kids
three point fours was like three four
now
you know I I don't think if a guy wanted
10 kids genuinely where would he get it
because even the more conservative women
you know
they're not really willing to to have
that many children and you know I just
think it's been generation after
generation after generation of mothers
not teaching their daughters how to be
wise and I really think this last
generation of of wives was like the
worst you know they're career women
or bum women that just divorced and
lived off their husbands the ones that
stayed married didn't submit like at
least our grandmother's generation and
like great grandmothers you know while
they did have the propaganda and they
still you know
were a part of like the non-submission
submissive culture like you'll find a
lot of people in that generation were
separated but not divorced you know at
least they tended to have traditional
skills a lot of could cook a lot could
sell like they they had things to offer
but unfortunately like most of the women
today we really haven't been raised to
be wives and you're not really going to
find many women with real cookbooks
you're not really gonna find many women
um with traditional like real
Traditional Values and unfortunately I
think when conservatives come in and say
just get married and stay married I I
really think that's something every guy
has to decide for himself they really
have to weigh the options and decide
what's best for them because you know
um I guess I've just I I think I just
have a different experience because I've
interviewed so many guys that have been
absolutely wrecked by divorce and
honestly I think their lives would
probably be better if they went make
towel and just avoided women seeing what
they're going through like these are
guys on the brink of divorce and this
isn't to say that this happens to
everyone this isn't meant to be a
doomsdayer but I think we can't be blind
to what's going on in society like they
want you to like close your eyes and act
like it's not happening but even in
Rural America
you know we're seeing more and more woke
stuff
and even in Rural America we're seeing
women get more and more liberal give
more and more [__]
um I don't say this in a happy way but
again it's what I see and for some
reason I just think our society has this
like gut reaction to protect women that
you know saying something that's true
if it makes women look bad I just think
men and women have this visceral
reaction to just deny till they die
and that's why again this space is
really hard to be in because you again
it's you can either say what sounds good
or say what's true and I just think as
people we need to error on the side of
Truth so you know that's my that's my
two cents for today guys you know but
let me know what you guys think maybe
I'm just a doomsdayer you know
um I just hate women you know even
though I am one but let me know what you
guys think like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel and I'll
talk to you next time